an outpouring of solidarity on Paris's +
de la république thousands of protesters
turned out to express the support for
Frances Jews their anger magnified by
yet another desecration of a jewish
cemetry these were just one of dozens of
demonstrations nationwide in response to
a search in anti-semitic hate crimes I
think that anti-semitic actions are on
the rise so it's something that strikes
fear that brings back bad memories we
want to show younger generations that
there's another path to take panco
Sevilla this is what feud the outrage
the Jewish cemetery in the village of
quad sin Haim in eastern France defaced
with swastikas and other anti-semitic
graffiti French president in Mon Ami
McCrone has vowed to bring the Vandals
to justice and once more to stop
anti-semitism in his tracks
did you know a group of individuals full
of hate has unfortunately done what
others have done before for too many
years I'm here to express the Solidarity
of a whole nation it really seemed
editor and to express our complete
determination in fighting anti-semitism
whatever shape it takes this was the
second time a jewish cemetry has been
desecrated in recent months and France
in December nearly 40 graves and a
Holocaust Memorial were vandalized in
the same region it is attacks like these
that brought people together not only
ordinary citizens but also top
politicians and religious leaders they
wanted to send a clear message they've
had enough
okay let's go straight to Paris now our
correspondent Lisa Lewis Lisa can you
tell us more about these protests well
there were protests across the country
in about 60 cities really thousands of
people took to the streets about 20,000
in Paris the one in Paris especially was
organized by the Socialist Party and
many people from different parties came
to the protest that's why some people
actually say you know we don't want so
many politicians to be there we're
organizing our own protest there was a
second one in Paris organized by
anti-racist organizations together with
far left organizations civil
organizations and they were saying you
know we really want to stand up against
anti-semitism and we want to prevent
politicians from pick.this from freaking
this out for their own interests really
you know it comes at an important
juncture for France what's behind the
country's sharp rise in anti-semitism
we're seeing a 75% increase in
anti-semitic attacks year-on-year well
absolutely
it comes from different sides on the one
hand from far-right activists but also
you know the conflict in Israel has
traditionally be imported to France so
it is believed that amongst those doing
these anti-semitic attacks there are
also many people who feel very close to
Palestinians who somehow radicalized and
when you look at what who the government
just arrested after the incident on
Saturday against the Jewish intellectual
alarm finger court there's a 36 year old
man who was arrested in Murrells this
morning and he is known to be close to
the Salafist movement radical movement
of air of you know Muslims really so the
government looks at but both sides
obviously and is trying to chase this up
okay now at this are vandalized jewish
cemetery president micron promised a
crackdown what could it look like the
government is looking into actually
getting social platforms to control
their contents and I was speaking to a
Jewish to someone from a Jewish
organized organization here who is
telling me you know the rise in
anti-semitic acts is really also down to
all these social networks where it's so
easy to say
something and to just share it and
everybody agrees without double-checking
any facts really so the government wants
to crack down on this they're right they
are running some kind of trial until
mid-march to see how this works like
that platforms like Facebook or Twitter
should actually withdraw content that is
anti-semitic and then they're looking
into maybe putting out a law on this
this Louis thanks so much for that from
Paris
you